[inaudible]
in the last lesson I proposed that the nouns,
cases and the thematic rules of arguments might be two different things.
Now,
I'd like to illustrate that distinction with some examples and make this really
clear as we move on to considering alignment.
Let's look at some sentences in Katelyn,
a language spoken in eastern Spain and some sentences in Basque,
which is a completely separate language spoken in northern Spain in Basque.
The sentence Unic Bailey could see [inaudible] means John has seen Peter the
sentence be your CUNY.
Goosey do means Peter has seen John will translate those sentences into Katelyn
as one by they will look better and and better by Belden one.
In all of those sentences,
we can see that the subject and the object are clearly marked. They're distinct.
This is something we'd expect,
but something different happens when we look at in transitive verbs in the two
languages in Basque, let's use the example your narrowed eda
and in Katelyn, the parallel example is one bug elder.
Both of these sentences mean John fell in English in Catalan.
The subject of this sentence works exactly like the subject of the transitive
sentence in Basque.
It works exactly like the object of the transitive sentence.
This supports the idea I put forth earlier,
which is that cases and roles are treated as distinct.
If we look at the roles of those sentences with the verb C,
we have an agent in a patient with the verb fell.
We have an experiencer in Catalan.
The agent and the experience or role are treated identically.
They're filled with a noun. In this same case,
while the patient role is filled with a different case in Basque,
the agent role is filled with a different case than the patient and the
experience or roles we ended with now in roles filled with nouns from different
cases in different languages. Of course,
there are names for these two alignments. The first gets called nominative,
accusative and the second is [inaudible]. Absolutely,
and these aren't the only ways languages have of handling alignment either.
I hope you've been able to strengthen your understanding of grammar.
Take the time to review my other linguistics lessons and subscribe to learn some
interesting stuff about language. Thanks for learning with me.
[inaudible].